[Musique]
il arrive à un jour du mois d'août dans
ce pari fiévreux à peine sorti des
barricades qui s'arrêtaient de compter
ses morts
pour lui crier sa ferveur il rapportait
cette victoire qu'on avait perdu et dont
le 1er au 18 juin 40 il n'avait pas
désespérée et puis à ce peuple meurtri
que l'ennemi pendant quatre ans avait
humilié pour mieux la servir
il rapportait cette chose immense et
merveilleuse la liberté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais d'éveiller les cris et les bibans
en descendant les champs elysées enivré
du plus beau soleil de l'année général
de gaulle évoqué la grande pitié du
royaume de france
il percevait ses ruines il avait
traversé ce deuil infinie des villages
désormais sans nom les pierres désormais
inhumaines et est désormais interdit
d'évoquer cette misère a fini d'un pays
où la justice et la piété ne vivait plus
que dans les ruines où la pluie se
troubler encore le silence des usines
mort derrière ces images déchirantes
il y avait des réalités menaçant et
hypothéquer l'avenir 4000 km2 voire
encore 115 dans importante détruits sur
322 11 mille machines 400000 vagues ont
disparu ou blessés
[Musique]
oui
il y avait tout le réseau des
communications jeté à bas les artères et
tous les nems du pays coupé
[Musique]
il y avait les 8000 sont détruits de 40
à 44 et dont 700 elle avait été deux
fois
[Musique]
il y avait les port comme le havre le
port le plus détruit d'europe
no 22 corps principaux avaient subi les
destructions allemande
après avoir supporté les bombardements
alliés
comme boulogne il montrait les blessures
de leurs quais et de l'ordre et à toulon
le génie de la mère ne pouvait plus
désigné de son bras blessé qu'une flotte
englouti et un cimetière bas rhin
[Musique]
et
e
un an a passé la flotte engloutissent
hors de l'eau quatre-vingt mille tonnes
de navires dont les 25000 du strasbourg
le frère du dunkerque sont appelés à
reprendre leur route sur l'océan
un an a passé et tous les fonds onex ce
comme rené le havre ou 19 km de
questions 22 furent détruits
[Musique]
lorsqu'on songe qu'au total en france
n'encaisse 57% des quais 77% des formes
de radoub 68% des écluses 88% des engins
de levage 66% des hangars et 100% des
dock flottant espère et on vraiment
quinze ans après tous les efforts
seraient rouverts au trafic etc ont
recommencé à boire à quai les navires du
monde entier décharger leur cargaison
espère et on de l'activité portuaire
atteindrait en ou 45
presque la moitié de l'activité moyenne
en 1938 et pour en atteindre la totalité
en mars prochain
un an a passé et si dans les villes et
les villages voir si au feu de la
bataille des français vivent encore au
milieu des ruines soumises encore à ces
drames quotidiens de l'eau difficile de
la chaleur difficile de la lumière
difficiles des baraquements célèbrent un
peu partout pour remplacer
provisoirement les 450 milles immeuble
complètement détruite produisent en
france fournis par l'allemagne au titre
des réparations importé de suisse de
suède ou les états unis
ils couvriront 7 millions de mètres
carrés vivait en rive en effet et il ne
faut pas que les sinistrés cet hiver
n'est pas de toi c'est toi ils les
auront ils les ont au milieu des villes
démoli on doit s'élever ces
constructions faites de matériaux
récupérés sur place et où les habitants
attendront la reconstruction définitive
de leur foyer
[Musique]
on prendra sur place la brique le bois
la pierre tendre du pays pour donner des
toits à ceux qui n'en n'ont plus les
grands projets d'urbanisme qu'on étudie
pour demain donneront aux pays plus days
mais les sinistrés pourront attendre ses
réalisations sous des toits et derrière
détenait ils pourront attendre les
quinze cent mille logements prévus dans
le plan décennal
ils feront d'attendre le nouveau visage
de pierre que pris part à penser
architectes d'aujourd'hui des villes et
des villages de demain dont les
maquettes sont définitives et ne croyez
vous pas que c'est et cela l'essentiel
[Musique]
un an a passé depuis le temps où les
traces arrêté au bord des fleuves
[Musique]
ses pions d'abord des pincettes prêt
provisoire rejetée par le génie des
armées sur lesquels les convois
s'aventurait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
puis des constructions plus sérieuse
pire la place de ses pompes fortune et
4300 des 8000 pour disparue ont déjà
reçu rhji cers sur ce chiffre
560 18 seulement sont définitifs 3700
sont des constructions de bois et de fer
qui disparaîtront pour laisser la place
aux arches plastique
il y en au bliss en france chaque
paysage mais n'est-il pas considérables
déjà que les liaisons nécessaires étant
rétablie cette reconstruction des ponts
soient appelés à être totale dans six
ans et totale à titre définitif
[Musique]
m
et
oui
un an a passé et à côté de ces tâches de
reconstruction urgence le commandait le
besoin de vivre
on a vu reprendre ses grandes oeuvres
d'avenir que la guerre avait dû tenir à
l'écart sait-on que la france équipée
hydroélectrique mans pourrait devenir le
fournisseur d'électricité de l'europe
entière des hommes y pense
lebara cheney les noms des barrages de
génie siens de maresches de
saint-etienne parallèle de lardy de
laroque bout de neuvic d'ussel et de
l'aigle seront un jour une page
magnifique de notre reconnaissance
[Musique]
des hommes travaillent dans la montagne
des constructions babylonienne
recommencent à monter dans des sites
perdu un rythme que la guerre avait
brisé
[Musique]
oui
demain le sait la graphie ciel naîtront
des millions de kilowatts qui feront
tourner les roues rondes et des machines
et chanter les métiers
sans doute n'en sommes pas encore là
nous avons toujours besoin du charbon de
nos mines nous attendons encore des
mineurs la chaleur la lumière et la
force pour l'industrie et dans les mines
le manque de personnel et d'efficience a
mené par une sous-alimentation de cinq
ans le manque d'outils avait réduit la
production au point de pierre fabre le
pays mais grâce à l'effort des mineurs
conjugué avec ces mesures d'organisation
et de répartition la production
charbonnière en est à 70% de son rythme
d'autres fois nous ne manquerons pas de
charbon cet hiver
il ne s'agit pas bien sûr cette année
d'assurer notre consommation d'avant
guerre
ces 80 millions de tonnes dans lesquels
entrait pour un bon car l'apport de
l'étranger mais nous aurons un peu de
chaleur mais les usines tourneront mais
les trains ponctionneront
[Musique]
ils fonctionneront d'autant mieux que
voici un an les chemins de fer était à
zéro ou presse aujourd'hui
54% des locomotives circulent sur la
totalité des voix maintenant rétabli
et aujourd'hui également la métallurgie
accélère sa production
l'absence des stocks pillé par l'ennemi
ne permet pas de produire au rythme
d'avant guerre mais l'un après l'autre
aux fourneaux et fonderies se sont
allumés et toute industrie à leur suite
se remettre au travail
[Musique]
la construction aéronautique recommence
à produire une aviation nouvelle qui
demain tiendra sa place sur les lignes
aériennes internationales avec la série
de ces super hydravion dont le premier
entre en service sur la ligne en
amérique
[Musique]
nous sommes prêts aujourd'hui à tenir
l'autre place partout dans le domaine de
la science comme ailleurs n'avons nous
pas créés en france depuis quelques mois
une fabrication de pénicilline qui
s'accroît chaque mois
non
et n'oublions pas que nous sommes de
sciences ont été les premiers à se
pencher sur le problème de la
dissociation de l'atome et qu'ils ont
ainsi apporté leur grande pain à
l'invention de la bombe atomique
rien dans le domaine scientifique n'est
perdu pour la france
[Musique]
un an a passé aujourd'hui nous avons
récupéré une partie des biens que nous
avait volé les allemands les hormones et
j'ai trésor métallique trésor d'un
attaché aux collections françaises vont
bien déjà vont nous retrouver de toutes
ces choses qui constituent le patrimoine
national qui avait émigré dans les
souterrains et les mines de sel
d'allemagne
un an a passé et ses deux millions de
français y vivaient depuis des années
dans l'exil des camps nous les avons
aussi retrouvé la victoire où les a
rendus ligue 1 un an nou lé plus riom
songez-vous comme à cause de la vie et
changé comme leur tout à fait la vie
plus belle
[Musique]
et depuis un an avez vous compté les
progrès la france s'est fait reconnaître
comme une nation libre
elle a retrouvé avec la liberté de la
presse et la liberté d'opinion
cette tradition démocratique et la
retrouver avec la voix rendue à
l'électeur la liberté de se prononcer
sur l'orientation de ces destins avec le
droit de vote donnée aux femmes elle a
accompli une oeuvre de justice et
d'intelligence le jusqu'ici tous les
gouvernements s'étaient refusées à
accomplir
[Musique]
elle a contracté avec le peuple russe
une solide alliance qui nous est dans le
sens des combats sera fructueuse
le pacte qu'à moscou ont signé mais ce
que bideau et molotov en présence du
maréchal staline et du général de gaulle
est un des gages de la paix de demain en
europe
quel chemin parcouru en un an pour
l'allemagne de hitler a capitulé
la france était là au rang des
vainqueurs dans berlin en ruines
le général gaye fall a remis la
capitulation totale de l'allemagne aux
mains de la france en même temps comment
ses alliés devant l'allemagne
nous sommes aujourd'hui des braqueurs
français le général de la fdt a mis son
nom au bas de cet acte qui clôt une
phase de l'histoire la france retrouvait
sa place au nombre des grandes
puissances
elle devenait l'un des cinq francs sur
la route san francisco je suis truman
accueillait monsieur bideau et si nous
déclinons à san francisco le rôle de
puissance invitante
votre intervention entre les etats-unis
la russie l'angleterre et la chine
marc est parfaitement que l'organisation
de l'europe d'après-guerre ne pouvait se
faire sans nous
[Musique]
voici un an nous n'étions vient dans
l'échiquier des forces et sur le
missouri
au terme de cette bière d'extrême orient
qui s'étendit sur tant de territoire et
mobilisa tant de force
nous étions là pour recevoir la
capitulation japonaise
frais de macarthur la france avait le
général leclerc dans j'espère revenus il
faut organiser le monde de demain
c'est dans ce but qu'un invité par le
président des états unis le général de
gaulle a fait le voyage d'amérique
les derniers nuages qui pouvait
dissimuler les sentiments des deux
républiques soeurs ont disparu au
lendemain d'une guerre qui a failli tuer
la france et faire disparaître les
principes démocratiques sur lesquels est
basée la civilisation du monde libre la
france et les états unis sont d'accord
et sur ses principes de liberté que le
monde de demain s'établira et vivre à
cet accord et cette liberté car clamait
l'amérique en acclamant le général de
gaulle
c'est cette liberté quatre ans mais les
français le 18 juin exactement cinq ans
après le jour où un simple général à
deux étoiles au moment où les français
les plus écoutées un ticket disait non à
l'ennemi disait non à la trahison dit et
non au désespoir
[Musique]
c'est cette liberté que la foule
française a clamé à la bastille le 14
juillet cent cinquante six ans après le
jour les parisiens avaient mis à l'ordre
du jour cette liberté pour vices par nos
pairs et que l'une après l'autre les
généraux pendant 13 ans défendu cette
liberté mr des traditions républicaines
auxquelles nous sommes attachés
cette liberté qu'un jour de deuil un
français ramassés dans le story dans la
boum avec le nom même de la république
pourra amener à l'endroit même où il
était né en
[Musique]
et
m